and we're live
hello bernie how are you joe wonderful
pleasure to meet you
nice to meet you it's exciting to have
you here man and it's uh obviously an
exciting time for you um you know
presidential campaign is up in full
swing
do you do you get frustrated by the the
time constraints
of the debates ah absolutely it's
you shouldn't even call them a debate
what they are is
a um you know reality tv show
in which you have to come up with a
sound bite and all that stuff and it's
the meaning it's the meaning to the
candidates
and it's the meaning to the american
people you can't explain
the complexity of health care in america
in 45 seconds
nobody can but why is it still done that
way if you
try to let's pull this thing
um you know i think the dnc is in a
difficult position
they have 20 plus candidates and they
want to give everybody a fair
shot which is is the right thing to do
uh and then if you're gonna have 10
candidates up on the stage what do you
do
but there are other ways that we've got
to do it because the issues facing this
country
are so enormous and in some cases so
complicated
nobody in the world can honestly explain
them in 45 seconds and then that what
encourages people to do is to
come up with sound bites and do absurd
things if i yelled and scream on the
show i took my clothes off
uh you get a lot of publicity right if
you give a thoughtful answer to a
complicated question it's not so sexy
for the media
well you don't even have a chance to
give a thoughtful answer like uh tulsi
gabbard went after kamala harris
and then kamala harris had about 12
seconds to reply to it it was so
ridiculous to to to have something
that's such an important issue like
did you or did you not put all those
people in jail for marijuana did you
laugh about it did this happen did that
happen all these different things
was evidence withheld right that's how
these are
long conversations but it takes us to
another issue
and that as a nation we do a pretty bad
job
in analyzing and discussing the serious
issues facing our country
and i i hold the media to some degree
responsible for that you know other
countries what they do
is that joe you want to run for
president i'll tell you what whether
your party
in the general election we're going to
give you a certain amount of time
hours on television and you use those
hours any way you want you want a
15-minute
discourse you remember ross pro yes and
people used to laugh at ross perot
because he used to get up there with the
chart and all this stuff and
and the media made fun of him but in
fact he tried in his own way
to explain his point of view to the
american people and we need serious
discussion on serious issues well he had
the op
because he was so rich he had the
ability to buy air time
on network television which is pretty
unprecedented he just
bought a chunk of air time and then pled
his case
but you know what goes on in other
countries you don't have to buy that
time
what the obligation is if you are a
network you're going to make that time
free and available to candidates do you
think that that's something that could
be viable in america
could could you convince cbs and nbc and
abc to go along with something like that
no you couldn't convince them you'd have
to pass legislation to make that happen
but everyone's online today
i mean the entire country is essentially
getting email and facebook and all that
jazz
like why bother doing it in this
particular medium that has an inherent
time constraint
well you're right i mean the internet
has revolutionized
politics and in many ways good ways we
use
our social media our email list which is
very large
we every day we're sending out stuff and
other candidates are doing it the same
way but television still has a very
important role to be playing i'm sure it
does but i mean the ability to discuss
things in in long form like you can do
online like you can do right here right
now
right you can't get that on television
well you could i mean if you had sure
they would have just they would have to
interrupt you every 15 minutes
no no no no what i'm saying about is
it's in what goes on in other countries
if i'm not mistaken like don't hold me
to this i think in the uk
you remember the labor party you're a
candidate here's 30 minutes
of time and you do with it as you want
you want to speak 30 minutes on health
care whatever it may be you can do that
really yeah and they don't interrupt
with commercials no no no that's the law
that they have given
this is the candidate's opportunity to
speak at length to the people of the
country
what are the misconceptions of you
because here's here's the
if you go to the knee-jerk conservative
reaction you talk to people who are
not interested in anyone that wants to
be a democratic socialist
they hear the name bernie sanders the
negative implications are that
you are somehow or another going to take
their money
right is that annoying to you yes it is
of course it is
and also that i miss the maduro i'm a
dictator i love dictatorships and all
that stuff
and the truth is joe that if you look at
the
issues that i campaign on and what i
believe on they are really not terribly
radical they exist in many countries all
over the world
for example just we can start on
healthcare if you'd like
is the idea that healthcare is a human
right not a privilege
a radical idea i don't think it is it's
not and the truth is
we are the only major country on earth
many people don't know this
we're the only major country on earth
not to guarantee healthcare to all
people
as a human right and yet we end up
spending almost
twice as much per capita on healthcare
the function
and you can argue with me if you want
but the function of the current
healthcare system
is not to provide quality care at all it
is to make tens of billions of dollars
in profit for the drug companies and the
insurance companies
that's the function if you go to canada
and i live 50 miles away from the
canadian border you have major heart
surgery
you're in the hospital for a month do
you know what the bill is when you get
out
zero you got it you go to any doctor you
want you don't have to take out your
wallet
and yet they guarantee health care to
all of their people and they spend one
half of what we spend
that's kind of what i want to do and i
don't think that that's terribly radical
we have
a program now which everybody knows it's
called medicare was started by lyndon
johnson back in 1965.
it is a popular program uh all that i
want to do
over a four year period is to expand the
today eligibility
age of 65 want to take another 55 45 35
everybody over four year period that's
about it and i want to expand benefits
to include
uh dental care hearing aids and
eyeglasses uh as well that's about it
not too radical that doesn't sound
radical at all now when you say that
they that canada
spends less obviously they have less
people you mean less per capita yes half
per capita
exactly per capita and and the quality
of care
is as good or better do they have
problems yeah they have problems
everybody has problems
but overall the healthcare
experts will tell you the quality of
care there is is good or better
than it is in our country so what's the
hurdle okay i'll tell you exactly what
the hurdle is the hurdle
is exactly the same thing as in every
other aspect of our lives
it's the power of money all right listen
to this
over the last 20 years the drug
companies
alone have spent four and a half
billion dollars in 20 years on lobbying
and campaign contributions
that's what we're up against the
knowledge and i
mark my words within a short period of
time you will see tv ads california all
over this country demonizing bernie
sanders he wants to do this terrible
thing to you he wants to do that
they have unbelievable amounts of money
uh
and politicians are frightened of that
power give you one example
uh back in 2016 i got involved here in a
little way
with an effort on the part of the nurses
to control
the cost of prescription drugs in
california you may recall that effort i
do
it was a ballot item in one state here
in california do you know how much the
drug companies alone
spent to defeat that effort they spent
131 million dollars
on one ballot item in one state all
right
last year the top 10 drug companies made
69 billion dollars
a week ago i went to canada with a
number of americans
who are dealing with diabetes we bought
insulin
in windsor ontario for one tenth the
price
10 of the price same exact product being
charged in america
so you got drug companies that are
engaged in collusion and in price fixing
who are incredibly greedy and the result
is many elderly people many working
people simply cannot afford the medicine
they need this is
it's unbelievable and the reason for all
of that stuff is we are the only country
in the world that does not negotiate
with the drug companies they can charge
you any price they want
and that has to do with the fact that we
don't have a national health care
program medicare is not negotiating etc
is this something that can really be
implemented inside of four years
yeah it's an enormous endeavor well i
want you to think back think
back joe in 1965
uh you had lyndon johnson as president
and by the way this idea of national
healthcare
this has been talked about literally
since teddy roosevelt is not a newer
concept
healthcare is human right that's what
teddy roosevelt was talking about that's
what fdr was talking about
harry truman was talking about it
kennedy was talking about it
kennedy got killed lyndon johnson picked
up the mantle and and their
idea was according to people in their
administration will start with the
elderly who are most
impacted by by healthcare costs and
sickness
will start and they did in 1965 without
the technology we have today
they implemented medicare 19 million
people
elderly people signed up in the first
year so if you could start a brand new
program
and have 19 million people sign up with
a technology that is way way behind
where we are today
why can't we over a four-year period
simply expand that program i don't think
it's such a
a difficult uh operation so when you
talk about the drug companies and the
lobbyists and
the enormous amount of money that they
spend is this
does this exist anywhere else other than
the united states lobbyists on that
level
no no of course not uh and the reason
you know in canada what you have
is you have a national health care
program and so forth
and they sit down and hey they negotiate
with the drug companies they have their
own approach
but every other major country on earth
says to the drunk companies of course
you can't charge us any price you want
this is a reasonable price tell me what
your profits are what your expenditures
are
this is the price for us you can walk in
you know if you have an illness
you could walk into the pharmacy
tomorrow and the price has been doubled
and you say to the pharmacist what
happened he said they just raised their
prices
they could do it any day they want to
any price they want
now lobbyists are in in general when
people talk about lobbyists
it's an unattractive term we think a bit
in terms of a negative
we don't we don't think of oh thank god
there's lobbyists we think
wow there's someone with enormous
amounts of money using that money
to gain influence on politicians and it
shapes
regular people it shapes our lives
mostly in a negative way this is the way
most people look i'm not saying it's
correct
why why do we have that system in place
like why do we have
lobbies why is it legal for someone to
spend exorbitant amount of money
exorbitant amounts of money to affect
our civilization to affect
the way our culture works right now
you're taking us into a whole new area
yeah all right let's look let me detour
and i'll come back
today in america
you've got three people owning more
wealth than the bottom half of the
american society you don't see that on
television too much
no you don't three people you got the
top one percent owning more wealth on
the bottom
92 listen to this this is a statistic we
recently saw
came from the federal reserve over the
last
30 years the top 1 percent has seen a 21
trillion dollar increase in their wealth
the bottom half of america has seen a
900 billion dollar decline in their
wealth
so what you have in america today is a
relatively small number of
incredibly wealthy people and i deal
with these guys every day people are
always talking about rich
you don't know what rich is what
multi-billion dollar operations are
incredible power over our society
and if you were the pharmaceutical
industry and last year 10 companies made
69 billion dollars
in profit you're sitting around right
now saying all right that's great how do
we do better next year
what strategy do we have we'll put a lot
of ads on we're going to work with other
during the cnn debate that i've
participated in recently in
the debate right in the middle of the
debate the drug companies and the
insurance companies had an ad
telling how bad so-called how bad
medicare for all
would be so they they're smart guys and
they use their power over politicians
they use their power over the media they
spend billions of dollars on advertising
on media to make sure that they make as
much as they can in profit but it's not
any different with wall street
it's not any different with the fossil
fuel industry or the prison industrial
complex
these guys have wealth they have power
and they could care less about the needs
of working people in this country
and that's the dynamic of american
politics right now
and in our campaign look we're taking
them all on and i know it makes a lot of
people
uncomfortable but we are taking on all
of these
entities and all of their wealth and all
of their power and that's what a
political revolution
is about so the real problem seems to be
that they have this strategy of
unlimited growth
not that they're not providing
medication that people need to save
their lives i mean it's obviously
important to have a pharmaceutical
company of course of course
right so there's good that they provide
but the business aspect of it is where
the problem lies right right look they
have great researches
but if you check how they even spend
their money
you know they will tell you this all of
their money on research and develop
we're trying
we're tackling cancer with tackling
diabetes alzheimer's
the truth is of course they are but the
bulk of their money
is going off into what we call me too
drugs they make modest changes in a drug
which really doesn't improve
people's well-being in order to make
profits so the answer is yes
we need obviously vigorous research and
development
and by the way your tax dollars all of
our tax dollars
often goes to that research and we don't
get the benefit of in terms of lower
prices
so it's just it's a business model issue
exactly it's a greed issue you've got it
and how would one
stop that when you're dealing with this
the kind of influence that you're
talking about with
69 billion dollars in a year i mean the
resources they have
how would you stop that well that is
kind of what we call the 64 dollar
question yeah
and i'll tell you what i think this is
what i believe
if you think back on american history
and you think about the real changes
that have taken place in society you
think about the labor movement
and working-class people standing up and
saying to their employers we're not
going to be treated like animals anymore
you can't
hire and virus you can't work us you
know 15 hours a day we
we deserve dignity and you think about
the growth of the labor movement of
millions of people beginning to stand
together
and fight you think about the civil
rights movement you know
and it wasn't just dr martin luther king
jr it was again millions of african
americans in that white allies saying
we're going to end segregation and
racism in this country think about the
women's movement
a hundred years ago women in america
didn't even have the right to vote
think about the gay rights movement
think about the environment the only way
the change takes place
is when ordinary people come together
and stand up and fight and say that the
status quo
is not working and that's what i believe
and that's what we're trying to do so
with
the the message of our campaign is
it's us not me because i can't do it
alone let me be very honest with you if
i were elected president tomorrow
i can't do the things that i would like
to do
that i'm campaigning on unless millions
of people were working with me
to tell the corporate elite that they
cannot get it all
so how would that be implemented let's
say you become president you're going to
become president
what do you think i think we got a shout
out to you guys all right president
bernie
what do you do you get in there what do
you do okay first of all
you make a very clear you make it clear
to the american people
what your agenda is and i appreciate the
opportunity to talk about an agenda in
in more than 12 seconds what does that
mean all right we're going to fight for
medicare
for all we're going to raise the minimum
wage to a
living wage we are going to deal with
education in a profound well-being
a profound way because i worry about
what's going on in education today
everybody knows that the ages of zero
through four
are the most important years for human
intellectual
and emotional development right every
psychologist will tell you that
and yet we have a totally dysfunctional
early childhood
system we pay we pay our child care
workers starvation wages
yet working-class families cannot find
affordable quality
child care you've got our public school
systems
all around this country in in many of
them really
being challenged right now teachers are
underpaid teachers are working two or
three jobs
you got kids who can't afford to go to
college and here's something that is
just
unbelievable kids who have gone to
college
leaving school with fifty thousand
hundred thousand dollars in debt
unbelievable these are issues that we
have to deal with and i will deal with
them
and uh we are going to substantially
improve
in the quality of education in america
we're going to cancel student debt
by imposing a tax on wall street
speculation all right so you got to deal
with education you got to deal with
climate change
you know the truth is that donald trump
is dead wrong
uh climate change is not a hoax it is a
very very dangerous reality for our
country
and the rest of the world scientists
tell us we have less than 12 years
to transform our energy system away from
fossil fuel or there will be irreparable
damage all right so those are in
healthcare of course for all so those
are some of the major issues criminal
justice immigration reform
you lay it on the table you see these
are the issues that we are going to
focus on
and you rally the american people around
those issues and you tell people like
mitch mcconnell
who represents a very poor state in
kentucky
that mitch if you are going to oppose
raising that minimum wage to at least 15
bucks an hour
i will be in kentucky as president of
the united states
and we're going to have a rally because
you're going to have to stop
representing and i hope by the way that
mitch mcconnell is not
the leader i hope the democrats can gain
control over the senate
but appears we'll put enormous pressure
on him to do what the people want
every idea joe here's the bottom line on
this thing every idea that i've just
talked to you about
is supported by a majority of the
american people these are not radical
ideas
let's let's take these one step at a
time because you mentioned a lot of
important things there let's go with the
minimum wage thing now the argument that
i've heard about the minimum wage being
raised to 15
an hour is that there are entry level
positions for high school kids for
people that are just
getting their feet wet in the
marketplace they're learning how to work
they're learning
they're making some money after school
that they that
if you charge or if businesses have to
pay fifteen dollars an hour
to people like that to entry-level
people that they won't be able to stay
open
well first of all they will be competing
against you know if you're a business
and i'm a business and both of us have
to raise
our wages at the same level we both have
the same burden so it's
it's spread across that is what
my conservative uh colleagues will tell
you the truth is i don't have the
numbers right in front of me
that while it certainly is true that
young people do work at mcdonald's in
the minimum wage jobs
uh a significant and majority of the
workers are not
kids they are often and i've met them at
mcdonald's
they are workers uh who have children
themselves when we we worked very hard
to raise the minimum wage at amazon uh
and at disney
we put pressure on both of those
companies and they did the right thing
and when you talk to the people at
amazon
who got that raise these are not kids
these are people in their 30s these are
these are ordinary
adults who cannot make it on 12 or 13
bucks an hour so i think
the argument that all their old kids uh
is not really
quite accurate well not even that all
their they're all kids but that
if they are kids what would you think
about making a minimum wage for someone
who's under 18
that's different from a minimum wage
with someone who's a legal adult
i'm not i'm not for that uh i think we
do it and
and look many of these young people you
know have their own needs i just talked
to a young woman
um last night who is working going to
college working full-time trying to take
care of her family as well so i think
look the minimum wage has not been
raised in 10 years it is now 7.25 cents
an hour which is clearly
unacceptable um the cost of housing
california all over this country is
rising fairly rapidly
people can't afford health care can't
afford college
i don't think it's asking our employers
too much to pay at least 15
an hour minimum wage now i'm glad you
brought up amazon because one of one of
the things that always freaks me out is
when i find out that
enormous corporations that make billions
of dollars have tax loopholes where they
literally pay no money
how is that possible and how do you stop
that well it's the same thing as the
drug companies how is it possible that
we pay 10 times more for insulin in this
country
and for other drugs than the one in
canada or countries around the world
and the answer is it's power so what is
what is the goal of major corporations
in america
it's to be deregulated as much as
possible so
in some cases they can pollute our water
our air our
environment it's also not to pay any
taxes
trump campaign as you recall he said
my tax plan is not going to benefit the
wealthy
it's going to benefit working people
well turns out over 10 years
83 percent of the benefit at the end of
10 years goes to the top 1
that's what these guys though i remember
i'm the
call the ranking member on the budget
committee in the senate
and some guy came forward representing i
don't know one of the big business
organizations
uh and this is their agenda their agenda
was to cut social security medicare and
medicaid
and to do away with all corporate taxes
so what you have right now that's
that's what greed is about they want it
all so as you indicated you have a
company like amazon owned by jeff bezos
who happens to be the wealthiest guy in
america worth about 150 billion
amazon paid zero in federal income taxes
and it's not just them
dozens of corporations paid nothing or
very very little and on top of all of
that
you got these guys able to stash all
over the world
trillions of dollars trillions of
dollars
in the cayman islands in bermuda in
luxembourg and other tax havens that is
insane
and that has got to end um yeah
how is it legal to do that why is it
legal
joe it is legal because they make the
laws right
all right you know that is what
he you're touching now on the heart and
soul of the tragedy of american politics
how does it happen that on issue after
issue the american people the working
class of this country
want something nobody pays any attention
to it but billionaires want something
and it gets done and that has to do with
a corrupt
political system so right now if you are
uh the koch brothers or some
multi-billionaire
you say to the leadership of the
republican party in some cases to the
democratic money
hey guess what we're prepared to put
hundreds of millions of dollars into
your campaign
hundreds of millions of dollars coming
from one or two people
and here is my agenda i want tax breaks
i want a trade system
which will enable me to shut down in
this country and go to china or mexico
and pay people there
two bucks an hour i want to be able to
do more pollution because i don't like
all of this
you know money i have to spend
preventing uh pollution of the air or
the water that's what i want you to do
and by the way i'm worried about the
deficit so you may as well cut social
security medicare and medicaid
how many americans actually believe
that we should give tax breaks to
billionaires and cut social security
medicare and medicaid
very few that is talk to mitch mcconnell
get mitch on the show
that is exactly what he believes well
that's ridiculous right
and it seems that if you just took away
those tax breaks
the enormous amount of money that would
come from those
corporations having to pay their fair
share would take care of a lot of the
expenses of all these things that you're
proposing exactly
how like okay let's talk about the
education because
the idea of free education is a
wonderful thing for people
um i mean the idea that you get out of
college and
you're in debt in in an insane amount
that you might have 10 20 years where
you have to pay it back
and and i know many people that are
interested there are people who are
getting their social security checks
garnished right now
it's not 10 to 20 years in some cases
it's literally a lifetime
now a lot of that is
i mean it's got to in some way be
preventable by what we're talking about
here
absolutely all right and is that how you
would pay for it i mean
i'll tell you exactly how i would pay
for okay and we pay for
every idea that we have we pay for and
we pay for it by understanding that
today we have massive levels of income
and wealth inequality
and we have in many cases the wealthy
and large corporations being
nothing or very little in taxes here is
the issue in terms of education
40 50 years ago you were an average
american working class person
you graduated high school especially if
there was a union around
you can go out and get a job and make it
into the middle class you could own your
own home you could send your kids to
school
you lived a pretty good life made it in
the middle class
40 or 50 years later there's an
explosion of technology there's a growth
in
unfettered free trade and it is clear
now
that most people to make it into the
middle class
are going to need a higher education
that's college or maybe it's technical
training
in order to become a skilled worker
it is insane to me to deny
working-class people and lower-income
people the opportunity to get that
education because the cost of college
has soared
so all that i say is that a hundred plus
years ago the american people said that
we should have free public education i
went to a public school
my parents didn't pay a nickel went to
kindergarten i went through the 12th
grade pretty good education
in brooklyn new york all that i'm saying
is the world has changed
and a high school degree is not good
enough anymore
so expand that concept through college
now
guess what 50 years ago do you know how
much the university of california a very
great university cost
in terms of tuition how much virtually
free
what's it now i don't know but it's
pretty high it is hard thousands and
thousands of dollars
so you had great universities like the
university of california
city university of new york state
colleges all over this country
where tuition was virtually free and
then what happened
for a variety of political reasons
states and the federal government
started cutting back on higher education
and put more and more burden on the
student with higher and higher tuition
which is where we are today so all that
i'm saying is in the year 2019 2020
if our working-class kids are going to
go out and get the jobs
that are out there they need a they need
a higher education which should be
tuition-free in terms of the
cancellation of debt which is my view
you got 45 million people um
who are dealing with that i'll never
forget this this is where it really hit
me
i was in burlington vermont and i had a
meeting on an issue and a young woman
comes up and she says
she's a doctor she graduated medical so
she's very happy she's
practicing in a community health center
loves what she's doing he said bernie i
gotta tell you though
i am three hundred thousand dollars in
debt having gone to medical school
i couldn't believe it i was in iowa a
young woman
four hundred thousand dollars in debt
this is not unusual for medical schools
and dental schools and you know ordinary
people
fifty thousand hundred thousand dollars
for going to college or getting a
master's degree
we promised these young people he said
go to college go out and get an
education you'll get decent paying jobs
well the answer is they have not been
able to do that so what we have proposed
in one piece of legislation or two
actually is to
make public colleges and universities
tuition-free cancel all student debt in
this country
that will cost 2.2 trillion dollars a
lot of money over a 10-year period
we do this through attacks on wall
street
speculation which will bring in 2.4
trillion dollars
we bailed out wall street 11 years ago
and by the way these are crooks on wall
street
who engaged in legal behavior taxpayers
against my vote bail them out
if we can bail out wall street you know
what we can cancel student debt and
provide
public colleges and universities tuition
free when you say a tax on wall street
speculation
what exactly do you mean it will be a
tax on uh all
of the tr every sale of attacks people
buy and sell
stocks and bonds all of them we have a
very modest tax on that
and by the way it will have an impact on
speculation by cutting back on the high
frequency trading which we now see
so you would just there is there's no
current tax on correct
so you would put a small amount and that
would do the job that would
that would raise more than enough money
it's a very small tax it exists
say small how much it depends on on the
nature of the transaction but it's less
than one half of one percent really yeah
and that's because yeah because the
amount of stocks being sold
and so and this is not again a new idea
it's it's being uh done in countries all
over the world
what about here here's one of the
darkest things about student loans is
that if
if you go bankrupt it doesn't matter you
still owe that
and that that's kind of crazy i mean if
you have a serious medical issue
if you're you're held up whatever
whatever happens to you that's awful
you go bankrupt most of those things are
resolved
but not student loans right i mean again
this talks
to the and that has to do with
bankruptcy law
which was passed against my vote uh and
while you're on bankruptcy
and i should have mentioned this before
when you talk about the health care
system
a half a million americans every single
year go bankrupt
because of medical bills that they can't
pay but you're right with students i
talked to this guy in nevada never
forget it
guy says bernie you know i'm over my
guys in his 50s and he said you know i
i've been paying off my student debt for
years i'm going nowhere
because the interest rates are high and
i fear very much
which is the case that they will start
garnishing taking away my social
security checks
taking money away from me so people are
carrying this burden
the result is that they
can't in many cases get married and have
kids they certainly can't buy a home
they can't buy a car they are really
crushed
by this debt and what was their crime
what did they do
they tried to get a higher education i
think that's pretty crazy and a lot of
them
when they do this higher education
they're 18 years old imagine making a
decision when your brain isn't even
fully formed it's gonna affect you for
the rest of your life you've got it
exactly right and you talk to these kids
so how much debt do you
oh um what kind of interest rates you're
paying gee i really don't know they just
told me to sign over here
that's all right now right now
we are a week not even a week out just a
few days away from two
mass shootings in a row and whenever
these things happen
there's all these people that want
action but nobody knows exactly what to
do there's calls for gun control
there's calls for mental health reform
there's calls for i mean
what if anything can be done to stop
these things from happening and how
have you sat down and tried to come up
with some sort of a solution and
is there a solution look i would be
lying to you
if i told you i had a magical answer
i don't and this is such a
horrific situation i you know we were in
um you know we we had a town meeting uh
we were in nevada actually in las vegas
when el paso happened and uh we did tell
me and i said
okay let's take a moment of silence to
remember the victims and pray for the
survivors literally the next day
in another part of las vegas i have to
do it again
and i said i can't believe that just
yesterday we did this and i have to do
it again
this is i i don't know what the words
you know my friend beta or rock would
say it's
you don't know what words what what can
you say it happens again and again
who can imagine some lunatic walking
into
a school or a mall or just on a
nightclub area
and taking out an assault weapon and
shooting down people
and that we almost become to accept this
as a normal part of american life is
is incredible is is is is just totally
demoralizing
all right so here's what i think there's
no magical answer
and but let me tell you what i think
first of all this is the reality
the reality is that today as we speak
there are approximately
400 million guns in america today we
have more guns than we have people
we have between 5 to 10 million
assault weapons and an assault weapon as
you know is a military style weapon
designed to kill human beings
kind of rapidly so that's and then on
top of that
we have again nothing to be proud of but
you know we have a number of
mentally unstable people people for
whatever reason i walk in the streets
they're suicidal they're homicidal
that's the mix that we have i think the
answer is and i'm not
the guy to invent all these ideas but
here's some of what we have to do first
of all
if you want to own a gun in america
you have got to we have got to know that
you
are a stable person and that means that
we need to expand
um
the background checks that currently
exist okay so we got to know did you
beat up your wife
have you committed crimes uh et cetera
et cetera
what is the state of your mental health
uh number two we gotta make that
universal
number two right now that
there is a background check if you walk
into a gun show
into a gun shop but you can buy guns in
various states
at a gun show and you don't have to do
any of that
so you and i go to a gun show you sell
me a gun i don't have to and
you know i don't have to do that third
of all i can today
legally walk into a gun show
uh pass the background check and buy a
dozen guns
walk out and sell them to criminal
elements who will use them for bad
things
so i think those are issues um that
most americans believe we have got to
deal with and we can
fourthly i happen to believe and i
believe this for 30 years
that we should not be selling or
distributing assault weapons in this
country
uh they are weapons of mass destruction
in a sense they kill people rapidly as
we saw
and thank god by the way when we talk
about both dayton and el paso thank god
cops were there very very quickly and
did an incredible job
because that guy had walked into the
nightclub there could have been
dozens and dozens more people killed in
in within a few minutes time
um i happen to believe a that we should
not be
selling or distributing assault weapons
in this country that's my view
period uh so i believe in a ban on
assault weapons and i think we have got
to begin
thinking about when we have five to 10
million assault weapons which is more
than the us military has
we have to think about a strong
licensing procedure
in terms of who owns these assault
weapons so that's some of
what i think there are many other things
but those are some of the ideas that are
out there
now the legal gun owners who are law
abiding citizens who would never
in a million years think about going
around shooting people but they love
guns they hear this kind of stuff about
like banning assault
rifles banning assault weapons they
don't even like the term assault weapons
right they like to refer to them as
their individual names or whatever they
are
these people feel like this is an
inexorable part of being an american
that you should be able to own a gun
it's written into our bill of rights
it's written into our
the the way we the way this country was
founded it's the second amendment
what do you say to those people that
don't that don't want to give up their
guns but they wouldn't do and they want
to protect themselves they feel like
these guns are viable options to protect
themselves from criminals
i understand that and joe as you may
know him a senator from the state of
vermont
and the state of vermont is one of the
most rural states in america
every form we've got a whole thousands
and thousands of people around the woods
hunting and it's something that's part
of our tradition i believe in it i
believe in the second amendment
but all that i ask of the gun owners and
you're absolutely right 99.9 percent of
gun owners would never in a million
billion years think of doing these
horrible things
but in the moment that we are living in
uh i think that we're all going to have
to make you know some concessions
to the reality of what is going on and
that is that there is a small number of
call them what you want to brave people
who are prepared to do that
you know in australia you'll remember
that terrible uh
new zealand i'm sorry the terrible
shooting at the mosque
and they moved pretty quickly uh in an
aggressive way so
you know i wish i can say in in the best
of all possible worlds
yeah you know you can own any weapon you
want and so forth and so on
we're not living in the best level
possible worlds we're living in a world
where we're shocked every day by hara
so i i agree we are living in a terrible
situation i mean there's
hundreds of mass shootings a year now
which is
insane and if you look at the number in
comparison to the rest of the world
it's crazy like a big one in another
country like three mass shootings in a
year
we had more than 270. that's right it's
it's crazy but
how would you implement something like
this well
the idea of banning assault weapons has
been done
in 1994 we'd banned assault weapons
uh i believe i believe it was for ten
years
uh that ban was undone by republican
majority
uh and it didn't you know i'm not
suggesting by the way that anything here
that
if you banned assault weapons tomorrow
that would radically change everything
but
we have got to do the best that we can
do
and again i preface my remarks by
telling i don't have a magical solution
you got hundreds of millions of guns out
there you have people who should not be
owning these guns
who get set off by god knows what and
and do terrible things all we can do is
the best
that we can do but to say we can't do
anything i think is a real disservice
to the american i'll tell you something
else that bothers me
you know in addition to the horror of
seeing people lying on the street
dead is what this is doing to the
children of this country and i think we
underestimate that
i have seven grandchildren and and
for them and for kids all over this
country
you're gonna see the falls coming kids
going back to school you're gonna see in
schools all over america drills
all right this is what you do if
somebody walks into the school
all right you're gonna hide under here
you go over there
kids i i a couple of months ago i was in
iowa this guy is about six foot two
big guy probably a football player and
he says
senator sanders i got to tell you that
the young people in my school are
increasingly
frightened terrified about what could
happen in the school
think about what this the trauma the
trauma
of what this gun violence is doing so i
think we're all
as americans there ain't no easy answers
here but they're all going to have to
come together and and figure this one
out and and
do the best that we can now would that
mean
forcibly removing these guns from
people's homes
i don't think you're going to have the
fbi knocking on somebody's doors and
taking that that's not what we do in
america you know
we have 400 million guns already out
there and they're building more every
year right now as we speak
gun manufacturers or make manufacturers
are making more guns
this is happening right now so if those
guns already exist it's more than enough
oh yeah how would you stop well again i
think
look you know i do think there should be
a ban on assault weapons so that means
that manufacturers
would not be able to produce or sell
those weapons to american citizens
but not to the military obviously
obviously yeah okay
so you know and your point is well taken
if you got 400 million guns out there
you know so i i think there are
approaches no one has any magical
solution but i've given you
i'll tell you something else that i
didn't mention and that is the role of
gun manufacturers
is that if you are a gun manufacturer
and you are
selling a hell of a lot of guns to a gun
store in an area
which normally you would not think i
mean these guys know
you know what cities buy what towns buy
how many guns
and if suddenly there is a tremendous
demand
you got to be thinking and be why is why
is this gun store buying so many guns
doesn't reflect the population in the
area you got to deal with that issue
with the gun owners
have to take some responsibility besides
the guns the gun manufacturers i'm sorry
right
besides the guns the gun manufacturers
the other gigantic
issue is mental health the only way any
of this
ever happens is someone has to be
insanely mentally depraved that's the
only way
and many of them are medicated
and many of them are on pharmaceutical
drugs and they have been
since they were children including
amphetamines like adderall
and prozac and all this different stuff
that has
varied effects on the human brain what
could be done and what would you done to
analyze this
to find out what the cause and effect
are and to try to figure out what
what role and how much these drugs are
responsible
okay well two things let me response
respond first by saying it goes without
saying that we have a mental health
crisis in america before we even talk
about drugs
and for whatever reason um you know
there are a whole lot of people and the
nature of our healthcare system getting
back to healthcare is
i just talked to a woman literally last
night
um and we had a a town meeting
and she said this is unbelievable she
said
bernie i was in las vegas
when the terrible shooting took place
okay
and now i am and i can understand this
perfectly i'm seeing
dayton and i'm seeing watching
television el paso
and i'm getting a pt ps ptsd reaction
all right and that's totally on if you
were in a place where people were shut
down
and [ __ ] i'm trying to get counseling i
can't find it
i remember a guy called up a woman
called at my office in burlington
vermont
and she said i'm worried about my
husband
what he my brother was his brother what
he might do to himself or somebody else
we're looking for mental health
counseling we can't find something that
we can afford
so we need above and beyond gun violence
we need and that's why i believe in
medicare for all
mental health is health care you break
your arm that's a health issue
that's a medical issue mental health is
a medical issue
and we have got to make mental health
counseling
available to all people in this country
when they need it not six months from
now
at a price they can afford and under
medicare for all it would be free
so that's number one number two your
point about uh
studying the impact of drugs
uh on people's behavior and possibly
resulting in violence
absolutely deserves to be studied we
should be studying the impact of drugs
in my view this is a layman's view you
know i'm not a psychiatrist
i worry very much that we are over
medicating kids in schools you know we
have this
uh deficit the deficient issue you know
kids are running around and they're
active
you know when i was a kid people used to
run around they were active you know
what they wasn't
they weren't drugged up so i worry about
that whole business but your point is
well taken i think we need to study this
issue
and make sure that these drugs in fact
are not causing
kinds of reactions that we will regret
later
now on the subject of drugs marijuana is
obviously a big issue in this country
and we've seen many states make it
recreational including this one what do
you think
could be done and what should be done to
have this across the board especially
federally
you know there's a guy that i have on
the podcast coming up soon his name is
john norris and he wrote a book on
the cartels growing marijuana illegally
all over this country and selling it
especially particularly in california
now because it's a misdemeanor because
it's
legal recreationally and selling it with
all sorts of horrible pesticides
on it all sorts of like very in fact
deadly chemicals all of this because
it's not federally legal because we
can't have
sanctioned licensed companies doing an
ethical job of growing something that
any responsible law-abiding person
should be able to consume
okay um let me say this
when i ran for president for the
democratic nomination in 2016
i talked about a broken criminal justice
system
which ends up having in the united
states
more people in jail than any other
country we have more people in jail than
china does which is a communist
authoritarian country and
what i called for then and i call for
now
is the legalization of marijuana in
america right now you have a federal law
it's called the controlled substance act
he has heroin here is marijuana they are
at the same
level that is insane heroin is a killer
drug you can argue the pluses and
minuses of marijuana
but marijuana ain't heroin so we have to
end and that's what i will do
as president of the united states i
believe we can do that through executive
order
and i will do that second of all what we
have now
is a number of states and i'm very proud
i talked about
during 2016 what seemed kind of radical
the need to legalize and decriminalize
marijuana a very radical idea
four years ago it is spreading all over
the country and by the way it blows my
mind
to drive through nevada i think here
even in california now you see signs
corporations buy our marijuana yeah and
four years ago people getting arrested
they're doing that right their lives
being destroyed well particularly nevada
there was life sentences given out in
the 70s
can you believe that and now you have
corporations selling the damn product
that people
went to jail for um so i i think
ultimately you know we've got to
legalize uh marijuana and what's
good news in a sense is some communities
some cities
are expunging the records so if you were
arrested
uh have a criminal record for selling
marijuana that is being expunged and
that is the right thing to do
you know we can argue about the pluses
and minuses i'm not a great fan of
of drugs other people you know i smoked
marijuana a couple of times
didn't do much for me other people i
guess have different impacts just a
couple times
that's really true it didn't do much for
you yeah it made me quick getting it
know i was in vermont northern mindanao
that's the problem maybe yeah
it'll do something for you well made me
cough a whole lot all right but i got
other people have had different
experiences correct sure yeah
i certainly have um the other problem
is of course with illegal drugs comes
you get this horrible cycle particularly
in uh inner cities where you have people
that are incarcerated for illegal drugs
illegal drugs seem to be the only way
out
the hard drugs when we're talking about
cocaine and all these other drugs
how how does one stop that and would you
ever consider legalizing all drugs or
decriminalizing
no all drugs not at this point no i
wouldn't but
you're touching on a real tragedy yes
and
when we talk about criminal justice in
america we have over two million people
in jail
they are disproportionately african
american latino and native american
and here's what i think i think in the
wealthiest country
in the history of the world what we have
got to do
instead of building more jails and
locking up more people
we really do have to invest in our young
people especially
young people in distressed communities
what does that mean
if we can and we can do this with the
proper amount of resources make sure the
kids are not dropping out of school
if you drop out of school today you know
so you drop out in your second or third
year of high school you don't have an
education you don't have any job skills
what are you gonna do with your life and
the answer is you may well do drugs
you know or you'll get in trouble
self-destructive activity or
destructive activity you're gonna end up
in jail it makes so much more sense from
a humane perspective
protecting our people as well as a
financial situation we're spending 80
billion dollars a year to invest in
these kids what does it mean
it means making sure they get the
education that they need paying
attention having
good schools making sure that they get
the jobs that are out there
doing job training there was a principal
in a school in southern vermont i'll
never forget what she said it was a
working-class school
and she said bernie i love these kids i
am not going to let them drop
out and she had a mentoring program just
watching the kids who are mostly at risk
so that they would not end up uh going
through the cracks and getting into
trouble
that's what we should be doing as a
nation and when we do that we invest in
the kids
we get them jobs we get them education
the likelihood is that
the likelihood of them falling into bad
ways is significantly reduced
all those things sound great the
uncomfortable reality about drugs though
is that when drugs are illegal criminals
sell them and there's obviously a need
for drugs in terms of
not necessarily a need but a demand for
drugs there's a demand for drugs in this
country
that's absolutely fueling mexican
cartels
and illegal drug runners inside this
country i mean there's there's a lot of
that
how do you how do you curb that if drugs
are illegal
but you're raising a deep question
yes all right so the question
essentially that you're asking is
what is the cause of the opioid epidemic
yes that's one
that's one of it but but the opioid
epidemic is is interesting because
there's so much of it that's coming
legally
right that's not the drug cartels that's
the pharmaceutical industry you're right
but you the heroine is illegal yes all
right now you're asking
this is a very very deep question which
we don't talk about terribly much
why is it that so many of our people are
turning to drugs
to alcohol by the way and i don't mean a
drink at night but i mean serious
alcohol problems
and tragically to suicide
we now have for the last three years
something that is a historical never
happened before
in modern history and that is our life
expectancy is actually going down
and this is hitting all over the country
but especially hitting rural areas
and what the doctors are saying is that
these are diseases of despair
despair so you're in west virginia
you're in rural ohio
or any place for a month any place
and the job you used to have earning a
decent living is now in china
your kid can't afford to go to college
maybe you can't afford health care
you've got nothing to look forward to
under that
scenario drugs become alcohol becomes
a way out and the worst case
suicide so i think what we're talking
about is why is this happening
as often in rural areas in herdman as
well
and how can we how can we
re-establish hope and optimism in the
american people
and that gets back to a whole lot of
other issues it means
if people have health care as a right
that will certainly play a role
in this thing and walk into the doctor
when they need but it also means
that people need decent jobs to pay them
a living wage that means we have to
rebuild
rural america we have to rebuild the
depressed communities
in urban america it means that we have
to have a great educational system
and people say oh that's great bernie
that's utopian it is not utopian
this is something that in the wealthiest
country in the history of the world we
can afford
and we should be doing rather giving
creating a situation where amazon pays
zero in federal income taxes
so to answer your question there's a
deep question and again i'm not here to
tell you
i have all the answers but there are a
lot of people out there who have
basically given
up hope and for those people i guess
drugs is
is the alternative so what you're saying
essentially is that
if we can do something to mitigate
despair then we'll do something
to at least stop some of the demand for
these illegals i believe that is the
case look if i am optimistic
if i'm excited about going to work
tomorrow and i'm seeing my kid doing
great in school
and you know when i get sick i can go to
the doctor's office and have a sense of
community my downtown is not all boarded
up because
businesses have left but we have we have
a community yeah the
like the strong likelihood is there will
be less diseases of despair and drugs
than we currently see now when we're
talking about
impoverished communities and chronically
when you're talking about
cities like baltimore or parts of
chicago and detroit that have just been
in a terrible state of despair for
long periods of time and it doesn't seem
like there's a way out the people that
are born there
the people that live there they live in
this state
of of despair what what can be done
to resolve all these terribly
impoverished communities
and bring them up to a standard where
these kids that grow up there
they feel like there is an out that they
do have an opportunity
and why is this not addressed when we
talk about making america great
wouldn't like fixing the worst parts of
the country be the primary concern
the the less people that grow up in a
terribly disadvantageous position
from birth wouldn't that be an important
thing and what can you do
to resolve that well joe i think you you
know you said it better than i can i
think you're right
you know when we talk about what it
means to live in a great
society a great nation a nation that
we're proud of
i'm afraid there are some people who
have incredible wealth
and power who say you know what's great
is that we're seeing
a growth in the number of billionaires
in america isn't that terrific
and we got one guy who's worth 155
billion dollars how great oh by the way
we're building more nuclear weapons and
we're spending
750 billion dollars a year on the
military isn't that extraordinary and by
the way you see the yacht that that
billionaire has
you know it's three miles long isn't
that great your point is that we have to
i think as i understand what you're
saying
we have to redefine what being a great
nation is about
we are not a great nation when we have
40 million people living in poverty and
in despair
we're not a great nation when we have
massive levels of income and wealth and
equality when 87 million people can't
afford
to go to a doctor today so to answer
your question
i think that as a nation we have got to
focus a great deal of attention on those
distressed communities
often they're african-american often
they're latino often they are rural
white communities
and that means making sure that the kids
they get the quality education
that they deserve making sure that we're
creating
good paying jobs in those communities i
voted against
nafta permanent normal trade relations
with china and other trade agreements
because i knew
that those agreements were written by
corporate america with the goal of
shutting down plants in this country and
moving abroad
and the result of that has been the loss
of millions of good-paying jobs
and the complete destruction of
communities
all across this country in the south and
all across this country
so we have got to rebuild those
communities
we have got to bring high-tech jobs not
just to silicon valley
uh but to rural america again i don't
have magical answers
but the goal is we will not understand
this administration
turn our backs on distressed communities
we will rebuild those communities
we will build the millions of units of
affordable housing
that we need now think about what it
means to a community now where people
are living in terrible housing or
housing they cannot afford
when we put young people to work
rebuilding their own communities
without become a an indication of hope
and optimism
i think it will we're talking about so
many deeply important issues and
all of them that will be under the
control
or at least the direction of the one
person who winds up becoming the
president united states
is it a impossible job i mean it seems
like being the president you
are managing so many different aspects
of our
economy our culture our safety
our environment international
communication and
it's so it's so in-depth how does one
person do a job like that
well one person doesn't do it and you
certainly don't do it by tweeting every
other day major policy issues i think he
tweets a lot more than every other day
you know what you do and this is the way
any sane president
operates is you need to be working with
the smartest men and women
from all walks of life who understand
these issues every issue we have touched
on joe is enormously complicated
and i can send out a you know 20 word
tweet on it but that doesn't solve it so
unlike trump you know we will bring
together
uh the best and most knowledgeable
people in this country to address the
housing crisis to address the
issue of of these diseases of despair
we didn't even touch on climate change
you know and then the future of the
planet how do we
lead the world in transforming our
energy system and creating the kind of
jobs that we need how do we revitalize
american democracy
so that instead of suppressing the vote
we're getting more young people involved
in the political process
so to answer your question it is not a
one-person job and anyone who thinks it
is is dead wrong
you need the help of a very strong
administration
that knows the issues that comes from
the ranks of the working class and this
is the promise i will make
all right my administration unlike
trump's is not going to be filled with
billionaires
who's you know basically very often
greedy type people who
it is going to be filled with the best
people often from the working class
itself from
the trade union movement people who are
going to help us create policies that
work for workers
and not just the billionaire class now
we're
getting to the end of your hour here so
climate change is obviously an enormous
issue for our country and for the world
what what could be done and what do you
think you can do as president
that can somehow or another slow down
this this process well first of all we
have to have a president
who unlike trump believes in science and
i do
and what the scientists are telling us
as i mentioned earlier is that we have
fewer than 12 years to transform our
energy system or else there will be
irreparable
damage done not only to our country but
to the world
now climate change is not just an
american issue so we could do tomorrow
do all the right things but of china and
russia and india and the rest of the
brazil
and africa does not do the right thing
you know we're not going to make the
progress we need
so here is what we have to do in my view
number one
we have to tell the fossil fuel industry
that they are short-term profits and
they make a whole lot of money
their short-term profits are not more
important than the future
of this planet i don't think that's a
hard cell to make
you cannot keep producing a product
which is destroying the planet
in the united states and around the
world so by saying that you're saying
you would have to move
we would have to move consciously away
from fossil fuels
no if so maybe and if we do that how do
you tell
the fossil fuel companies do you tell
them you can't sell fossil fuels anymore
there are a variety of ways to do that
but that is the bottom line
and and by the way in the midst of that
we do what we call is a um
a just transition the guy out on the oil
rig today
simply wants to feed his family and the
coal miners today
want to feed their families and we're
not going to leave them i'm a pro-worker
i have probably the strongest bro worker
record of any member
of the congress so it is not my
intention to throw these guys out on the
and women
out on the street and ignore the pain
that they will go through
we are proposing billions of dollars to
rebuild those communities and make sure
that those guys
and women get new jobs so we're not just
discarding people in the fossil fuel
industry
but ultimately the product that they are
producing which is now carbon emissions
is destroying the planet so we have to
move away from fossil fuel in a very
bold way
into energy efficiency right now
in my own state of vermont and all over
this country there are buildings
which are incredibly wasteful we don't
have the windows we don't have the
insulation we don't have the roofing the
doors
that we need to keep the buildings warm
in the winter and cool
uh in uh the summer and we can create
just an incredible number of jobs just
retrofitting our buildings
second of all uh we need to move very
aggressively
uh to sustainable energies like wind and
solar in california you're doing a good
job
with wind iowa's doing a good job texas
doing a good job we got to do
much more solar there is incredible
potential out there price of solar has
dropped
in recent years and we have got to not
only
transform the energy system in our own
country we got to lead the world
in working with russia and china because
in this
issue we are in it together and here's
my dream and maybe
this may be a utopian dream the world
right now is spending a trillion and a
half dollars
on weapons of destruction designed to
kill each other and maybe just maybe if
we had a kind of leader and i hope to be
that leader who says to the world
instead of spending a trillion and a
half dollars killing each other
maybe we use those resources to
transform the global
energy system and save the planet for
our kids and our grandchildren
that's the goal that i have well these
these ideas sound great but in the
competitive environment of global
politics how would you convince russia
or china or any of these countries
to do something that would put them in
some sort of a competitive disadvantage
well and the answer is joe if we do not
do that in 50 100 years everybody's
going to be
a terrible disadvantage and look i'm not
you know i'm saying
i'm not telling you that tomorrow it's
going to happen but you got to make the
case these people
you know putin is a dictator i dislike
them intensely you know chi in china
very authoritarian stuff and so but
they're not crazy people and presumably
they have concern about their
kids and their grandchildren this is a
planet
under siege you know i don't want to
become a science fiction you've all seen
the movies the media
racing toward earth we're going to blow
up the earth what do we do well we got
to get together
this is in a sense what that is about
you know what i think about
in 1941 uh
after pearl harbor all right we were
faced
with a war in the east with china a war
in the west in europe with hitler
within two years the united states had
transformed its economy
to address and win the war basically in
two or three years by reindustrializing
tomorrow
we can do it we can lead the world
that's what we have to do
so in urines we have to look at the
economy almost as if the same kind of
threat
or excuse me the environment as if it's
the same kind of threat as nazi german
and act together look if you asked the
defense department you asked the cia you
asked the defense people all over the
world tell us what the great national
security threat is you know what it is
it is climate change
there's a lot of people though that are
skeptical of this how would you convince
them i mean this is a big part of the
problem right there's a there's a
narrative that you hear from a lot of
people
that oh you know climate change is not a
proven science and climate change is a
hoax and
i mean this is something that's repeated
over and over again and
i'm sure some of it has to do with
lobbyists and some of it has to do with
merchants of doubt that go out there and
seed the world with
disinformation to try to increase their
profits and continue the practices that
they're currently enjoying
you know joe when i'm thinking back and
i don't know if all you listen
can remember this because molded the
most but i can remember
tobacco adds cigarette ads on television
remember yes doctor guy dressed in a
white frock
smoking away this is a great cigarette
it'll improve your health they lied
the tobacco industry knew exactly what
was going on and the fossil fuel
industry is lying right now
and the president of the united states
is either too stupid
to understand what the scientists are
telling us or he is lying as well
climate look i am not the scientist this
is not my idea i
listen to the scientists the debate is
long
over climate change is real my god look
at what's happening around the world
today the great worst
you know july was i think the warmest
july or warmest month
in in the modern history of the world uh
the arctic ice is is melting uh heat
waves in europe
all right just look out the window at
what's going on
uh so this is not bernie sanders talking
this is the scientific
community climate change is
real it will only get worse if we do not
act boldly to cut carbon emissions
well we just did an hour sir so i'm
going to let you go because i know you
got very important things to do one last
question
if you got into the office and you found
out something about
aliens if you found out something about
ufos would you let us know
well i'll tell you my wife would demand
that i let you know does your wife at
ufo not
no she's not a ufo no it's just bernie
what is going on do you have any access
to the records
you don't have any access i don't know i
don't know okay you let us know though
all right i'll be on the show we'll
announce it on the show please all right
thank you sir appreciate your time joe
thank you very very much